hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to I gotta
say I've been getting a lot of letters
from people asking me what's going on
with the Angry Video Game Nerd is the
feud over let me tell you something
the feud will never be over as long as
that shit-eating cotton actor is still
around I will always be there to hand
him his what was that hell's going on
what the flight crack aah
so you're still talking shit about me
huh I will never stop talking shit about
you until you'll retire or die or retire
then die or die then retire all right
things have gone far enough I have one
thing left to say to you I'm sorry
bring it on nerds you want a piece of me
I what now seriously when I sat down and
reboot that Ricky one movie I realized
how hard it really is to have to sit
down and review a movie like that oh
well um to be honest I mean babe a kiss
was a real pain in my ass I guess I
didn't realize that reviewing horrible
games isn't all that easy either yeah I
mean seriously why are we doing this I
don't know it's pretty ridiculous isn't
it yeah I mean it really doesn't matter
I mean just the fact that I'm the better
talent I mean no but it really cares
it's not a big deal yeah yeah I just
have a point there you know it makes me
realize that um what uh yeah but don't
worry I mean it's not like you have to
stop making your inferior videos suck my
big fat sausage you fester a ton of ass
yeah fuck you you fucking cocksucker
fuck fuck fuck Bart
all right let's settle this let's settle
this once and for all a giant epic
battle of nerd on quitting action
violence to the death okay you want your
nerd on critic action will then show me
that you have the balls get your ass
over here and we'll have the final
battle all right now let's settle missus
let's settle this forever get your ass
over here fine
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it well you know the final
battle between me and the nerd is still
a while away but that doesn't mean you
can't contribute in the shameful
promoting of it that's why we have the
final battle poster contest we're
looking for talented artists to make a
poster for the big epic fight between me
and the nerd the winners will get their
artwork shown in the actual video how
does it work it's pretty easy first you
create an account at deviant art calm
and don't worry it's totally free next
upload your artwork onto your deviantART
page then you send us an email or note
with a link to your artwork to this
address and we'll post it under the
favorites section for everyone to see
it's that simple you can choose any kind
of medium you want drawing painting
Photoshop whatever there's even some
stills on the page which you can use as
a reference or you can just put them
directly in the poster you can use other
photos of us too if you can find them
the deadline is October 7th before
midnight Eastern Standard Time so get
the word out get on creating and don't
forget to see the final battle October
10th on both cinemassacre calm and that
guy with the glasses calm make us proud
kids and remember I'm a lot more
muscular than the angry video game just
Sam